تنضم الينا هنا في الاستوديو مصممه
الازياء هبه حوران هبه صباح الخير
احنا لانه قاعد يقولولي سريع سريع فراح
ندخل قاعه المحكمه بدون
قلب ندخل هذه القاعه نبدا بهذه الصوره
اللي راح تعبر عن موضه الصيف وهذه الصوره
عباره عن بنطلون
جينز ذو الجيوب لوك نسائي هذا هذا هو
عنوان الموضه لربيع سيف
2023 هذا
خلينا نشوف اللوكات النسائيه بس هذا نعم
او يس اكيد يس ليش
حتى بقصات مختلفه يعني البنطلون لازم يكون
واسع اكيد واسع وفيو كتير جيب اكيد خليني
انا راح اروح على الرجال ما لي علاقه
انت نسائي
بتكون برضه واسعه
في هذا
ما تلبسه يا صبايا باهد جدا والموضه خلص
خلصت موضه السمبل اللي يكون هيك خلص بدنا
نكون شوي بولد اكتر
هذا نعم هذا نعم اكيد فهلا موضه الالوان
الوان
الشمس يعني كل شيء طبيعه بتعطي بهجه راح
تكون موجوده
بصراحه هلا فيك كيف ما فيك يعني فلات
بيمشي الصبح مع هيلز مع شاي بيمشي للمنشوف
اللوك اللي بعده
تكفون رجالي
لا لا
قديمه
منقط ممكن يكون من ضمن موضه السنه ولكن
خلاص الورود بانواعها خلاص ممكن ترجع
بعدين ولكن
اللوز كات مش ضروري يكون الجيوب موجوده
ولكن الاطلاله المريحه الفاتحه اللي بتكون
خلص يعني انت طالع بالصيف ما بدها تكون شي
طايت عليك فاكيد
المفترض ولا
[موسيقى]
ماكو سحر
انت بتقولي نعم انا بطلع بقول لها للح
قيقه ما قلنا
قبل الوان حتى للرجال لحتى نعطي هيك طابع
الحياه يعني ممكن بس بدي اشتري لك هذا
راح نتقبل بعد والله انا اسفه
تنوره يعني
انا اسف والله
على
طب حلو
ممكن الاشخاص الكلاسيك اللي هم بالسيف
سايت يفضلوا يكونوا بهيدي الزون ولكن لا
يتطابقون
جميل
الالوان النسائيه راح تكون عندك البينك
الرجاليه في عندك الالوان البارده اللي هي
السماوي والدارك نيفي
هيبه حوراني شكرا جزيلا لك نشوفك مره
ثانيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات